hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Katie Dubois
we're gonna watch the trailer for the
horror movie called the hollow the
hallow the hallo hallo that's easy you
think you would say hallo the hollow
what just called up in a hollow I think
I saw a trailer for this we don't have
to be contextual just this is a hollow
is a noun
he was he loved God
you know can you take me a seat please
first falling in hand it's an old place
everything's okay okay you're making
people nervous he's in the forest again
a thief he's trespass expanders for him
they believe that the forest is your
trampoline or belongs to the hollow
hollow fairies but she's baby stealers
so you're believer mr. edge this is in
London
thank you go pop another just baby
dreams if you trespass upon then dare
trespass upon you
gloria really can't watch you feel
something take my hand
it's my nipple you feel that I reckon
it'll do
it's called chills KT chills horror
chills sorry for taking sexual advantage
of your right I gotta say that a [ __ ]
monster flick that's cool I haven't seen
a great monster flick in a while I
actually like and I have no idea what
the monster is that's what's cool about
it is you see like quick glimpses of
what might be the monster but maybe it's
not the monster maybe it's some other
type of things but one of the monster
like shadow of the monster
yeah there's Bloody Disgusting called it
a creature feature and I feel state
because I don't remember exactly what
creature feature means actually there's
a band called creature feature and
they're [ __ ] awesome shout out to you
guys like Bloody Disgusting you even
good feedback Hollywood Reporter
Fangoria and you know a lot of times in
movies and dance ya played at Sundance a
lot of times when movies that's what it
means
Bobby will say official selections
Sundance beer alone must be good well at
least I had to get pics out of probably
thousands of not every movie that comes
out of Sundance is actually good you
know Warner Brothers makes a lot of good
movies but doesn't mean every one of
their movie is good that's true what I
like about the critic reviews on this
one is that these are respected critics
this is like from Bloody Disgusting to
say that and Hollywood like that's crazy
to see that they're saying this preacher
feature movie is actually terrifying and
it looks pretty [ __ ] scary that's
beautifully filmed that is one of the
things you could walk away from from
this for sure no but yeah I mean I
feel really like I'm in this hollow yeah
feels haunted landscape it's like it's a
surround sound lansky yeah exactly
it kind of has a little bit of an
American Werewolf in London not you know
like about two people who are like going
on some trip and then you got their
backpacks going through the grass and
then right and they shouldn't be there
and one gets bitten and there's like
there's a legend out there hurry now
they're like European so kind of reminds
me your mom with like a good Scottish
Irish accent yeah it's delivering mm-hmm
there's no hollow out there yeah I bet
I'm like oh [ __ ] guy knows this guy
knows yeah the police officer knows I
would rather listen to him do it but no
no no it's good you want to feel like
break this trailer down just a bit like
go through it there were some quick
images that I was able to catch that
freaked me out that one part where the
mom is pushing down the floor right of
the hands appearing from above and like
rap [ __ ] like that freaks me out go with
the nails
yeah and they had that one moment where
let me see if I see yeah where the nails
like extending or something and it's
about to go into her I know I stuff and
mouth stuff don't do well with me you
rip off someone's jaw do that whole
thing where you stare here yep not cool
not push your eyeballs and I've got a
little bit more used to but poking the
eyeball are stabbing not cool with that
however I do want to see this because it
looks be kinda looks like if Guillermo
del Toro put together some type of
remake of American Werewolf in London
that's the vibe I get from this you know
what I'm hoping their comments are like
well said Ryan that comparison well said
yeah that way I get respect because it's
about respect in this business yeah your
criticism has
to have a larger poetic yes sense to it
it has to have worth hard-hitting
something genuine but also like yeah I
can feel that but I didn't think it
almost philosophical it's like a
philosophical approach this pensive
pensive something else okay I was like
why would you okay yeah when they're
driving in the car there's like these
creepy looking at ya you guys gotta slow
this trailer park yeah that is cool it's
the hull it so there's like creature
feature oh man that's cool so you have a
variety of possible different creatures
in this world because it's about in the
hollow it's better than one monster you
know it's it's kind of cool to have a
world established where it makes sense
or it's not just a bunch of random demon
[ __ ] and you don't know what's gonna
happen next and new monsters can't
emerge really different elements oh by
the way that thing with the baby freaked
me out when the baby started like
screaming dreaming yeah yeah cuz there's
there's always the baby thing on the
walkie-talkie they took it to another
level with making it seem like the
baby's actually being attacked or
something yeah that was creepy I guess
when you take she's documenting like
they realized they can take pictures of
these things yeah has sort of a found
footage element to it one thing about
movies where it's I mean some movies
have done it exceptionally well where it
does still scare me yeah but normally
when it's like one or two main
characters a level of fear can sometimes
go away from me because I'm like well
they're gonna at least survive her most
of the movie yeah I'm not sure how are
these people are gonna do yeah at least
one of them will survive or else we
don't have a movie for most of it at
least
all right where the camera needs to be
found however I think that a lot of
movies can pull off terror and suspense
really well without having to kill off
people okay like it dragged me to hell
was really funny Evil Dead 2 is great
the first paranormal activity scares the
crap out of me and that's just two
people the whole time I know they can
pull it off but I don't know kind of
like you're in creature feature I'm like
I'm
want some like grisly deaths from
monsters and stuff
we'll have to see yeah I don't know we
didn't get any people like being gross
their phone yeah that's my phone you are
so far from professional when you come
on this channel the hollow looks get a
holler looks very scary every time I do
Irish I always do this to follow it up
with it
all right I'm from Ireland I do I I
think of the Lucky Charms guy yeah
that's that's not gifts by Lucky Charms
and then sort of get I'm on my way
that's it's the best one it's the most
authentic accent I've ever heard anyway
guys if you the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
subscribe to Katie's Channel it's fun
fun fun and you can also follow her on
Instagram because she has one now bikini
pics that comes in and you follow me on
Facebook Instagram Twitter vine and
periscope let's do a shout out to a
[ __ ]
William beanie Douglas sup guys could I
get a shout out really love your videos
watch all of them you make me laugh and
enlighten my day you know what I want to
I want to risk uni we keep it the guild
work you keep running your channel I
want to work on receiving compliments
you know I was talking about that with
you like before like I need to work on
receiving things like beautiful it's
take it in allow them to give that to ya
it's hard but ok let me read this again
really love your videos you really love
my videos thank you watch all of them
you make me laugh in a line you my day I
make you laughing and light in your day
you know that does make me feel good to
know I'm contributing that to someone's
life is that they're feeling better when
they get a chance to hang out with me
through YouTube you're not really
hanging out with me it's really kind of
some social experiment if I look at the
camera
you're probably alone watching this so
you feel like you're here with me in the
room right now you're like oh wow he
really communicates as if like whoa he's
right here with me right now
but I'm not matter of fact I don't know
you look like William but I appreciate
you and hopefully I remember your name